io sono l'unica con una delle ultime
cose che vi separa dalla cena quindi
grazie agli organizzatori è sempre bello
partire avvantaggiati
allora è premessa avevo fatto le mie
slidin keynote che funziona benissimo
bene hanno convertite in powerpoint
quindi non is not my phone
comunque vorrei abbassare il livello
delle aspettative perché prima di me
hanno parlato negli oratori sapienti
io invece no io non ero neanche bravo a
scuola e ero questo quindi dei numeri ce
li avevo da piccolino poi sono mi dice
ancora intelligente mi impegnavo oggi
sono questo come vedete sono abbastanza
conciato anche se in pugno con
scioltezza il mio macbook air
cosa ho fatto
ho fatto un sacco di cose patapim e papà
nel frattempo ho avuto anche un infarto
però io volevo raccontarvi di cose
allegre quindi della rivoluzione che
viviamo quella del mobile allora
succedono succedono cose meravigliose
del mondo del mobile
ci sono dei giochi che hanno un successo
straordinario perché sono molto
intelligenti cioè degli uccellini
incazzati che ritiri con una fionda
addossa dei maiali verdi e cultura
oppure oppure robe come i social game
conoscete farmville che a chi ci gioca
bugiardino vele e allora sapete che in
questo gioco il gioco è gratis
però se volete far crescere le robe in
fretta
comprate del letame virtuale connesso al
di veri la razza umana sta migliorando
ok la gente compra un sacco di pop corn
nelle sale cinematografiche tre ricerche
su 5 si vede veramente di merda
presentazione
grazie grazie io ringrazio
ringrazio da questo da questo palco la
microsoft che un virus forma di azienda
per fare cosa va bene allora è allora
pensa il suo ma dai è il sabotaggio e un
sabotaggio
allora va bene io so dov'è state allora
200 milioni di video visti su smartphone
da youtube ogni giorno è un numero
abbastanza impressionante esattamente
come il fatto che il 65 per cento degli
utenti usa il cellulare per trovare un
negozio per fare un acquisto quindi
anche usando le mappe della apple
questo è la notizia che forse non tutti
sapevate la apple ha cambiato
completamente il suo modello di business
ormai fa un sacco di soldi col mobile
anche se siamo in un paese dove i
pagamenti mobili stanno succedendo
adesso sapete che sono in questi giorni
nel nostro paese i vari operatori stanno
lanciando prodotti presenti sul field
communication che consente di fare a
questi mobilità paypal se ne forte
perché tanto potete usarlo da qualunque
browser web e quindi è già un gigante
negli acquisti mobilità nel 2014 forse
anche prima
i terminali mobili saranno il primo
canale di accesso a internet
i nostri figli sono una generazione
mobil first moby nolli mia figlia quando
le ho detto di provare usare lymec mi ha
spiegato che era rotto perché quando lo
toccava non succedeva nulla
non fa ridere che diventeremo allora la
gente si muove
dovendo scegliere un oggetto tra
portafogli che a via telefono ovviamente
scegliamo il telefono anche perché a
breve il nostro telefono sarà sia
portafogli che chiavi e comunque tu
quando ti sei dimenticato il telefono
sei tornato casa prendono chi viene
un'ansia da deprivazione sensoriale
io volevo darvi alcuni ovviamente i
telefoni si sono mangiati lo spazio
delle videocamere compatte
ci sono degli sapete che ogni tanto
nella nostra industria
c'è qualcuno che darà i tagli analisti
allora c'erano questi fottuti geni di
morgan stanley che hanno detto che il
numero di smartphone venduti avrebbe
superato il numero dei pc nel corso del
vero falso è avvenuto nell'ultimo quarto
del 2010 e non ho questa previsione
l'aveva fatta nel giugno del 2010 ok è
praticamente gente che sa di cosa parla
volevo dire per oltre la metà del tempo
la cosa divertente è che noi il telefono
non lo usiamo per telefonare
ora siamo per fare tutt'altro ci sono
dei dati che sono impressionanti
sull'utilizzo vedete noi nel nostro
paese al mondo siamo al quarto posto
abbiamo un telefono e mezzo a testa
quindi tipo io un iphone o un blackberry
blackberry e il mezzo chiaramente ci
sono dei dati sull'utilizzo terrificanti
per esempio questo c'è il 15 per cento
degli americani risponde al telefono
mentre fa sesso e sembra non solo se la
moglie che chiama
ma la cosa più pazzesca sono quelli che
manda gli sms non parlo neanche
dell'internet delle cose velo risparmio
perché ovviamente ho quasi finito il mio
tempo che al fondo sa chi mi conosce sa
che io parlo dalle tre ore alle tre ore
e mezza
come usa il mio smartphone era quello
che volevo dirvi stasera in realtà per
costruire e difendere la mia identità
digitale cioè gli parlò di reputazione
cos'è la reputazione della reputazione è
quello che io dico di man e quello che
gli altri dicono di me ci sono delle
delle autorevoli sistemi di misurazione
della reputazione
frank mi dà un po fastidio questa risata
stiamo per la potete provare ognuno di
voi può fare questo esperimento
questo è un autorevole sito olandese che
ha pubblicato questo sistema di rating
potete vedere quanto ce l'avete lungo e
questa è la come come direbbe chris
anderson la coda lunga dice ci sono
sistemi un po meno autorevoli tipo
questo che comunque tentano di darvi una
classificazione alla vostra reputazione
da 0 a 100
io comunque sono 76 volevo dirvelo
e queste cose in realtà partono sulle
analisi di tutto quello che avviene nei
social media in cui voi vi rappresentate
e rappresentarvi nei social media ormai
dipende molto dall uso che voi fate il
vostro telefonino perché poi anche oggi
vedete come lalli freneticamente neanche
li guardi in faccia sta twittando
fotografando molto bello followgram te
lo volevo dire sinceramente un settore
chissenefrega dei vani the year el di
instagram che c'è followgram oppure
sistemi che tentano di darvi un
punteggio rispetto agli argomenti di cui
conversate sono cose che naturalmente
gratificano il vostro ego ma in realtà
sono tutti i sistemi che cercano in
qualche maniera di costruire delle delle
misure il pagerank di google non ci
basta più
ormai siamo nell'era della società
comandè shawn e quindi il punto è capire
chi sono gli influenzatori in un secondo
vi racconto le prossime 20 slide che mi
rimane allora cosa facciamo adesso non
don't è nick non sentitevi come loro che
dicono vai su questa roba del fuoco
forse stiamo andando un po troppo veloci
la buona notizia è che neanche
quando ha inventato la lampadina sapeva
cosa stava facendo
io vi possono comandare di costruire la
vostra presenza nel social mille si può
fare in maniera semplice non fate come
questo signore qui che un ingegnere
delle telecomunicazioni per esponevano
un tubetto di dentifricio segue la
strada della complessità si può fare in
maniera aperta questa come la open cola
la gestione delle vostre azioni sarà
migliore
il vostro lavoro sarà migliore stare
social media aumenta la vostra
visibilità di ori di grandezza non
nascondetevi non lo sopporto più perché
mi dicono che non hanno tempo di far
girare i [ __ ] patria
basta non è vero non diventate dei
tecnico idioti per favore perché questo
è un rischio
grandissimo e giusto per dire una cosa
saggia visto che dylan detta vi direi
questo
ricordatevi che gli analfabeti del
futuro non sono quelli che non sanno
leggere o scrivere sono quelli che non
saranno capaci di imparare di
dimenticare tutto quello che hanno
imparato e di imparare di nuovo io vi
ringrazio
questi sono i miei contatti grande